the building block skill in trigonometry
is being able to talk about the
different sides of a triangle in
relation to each other so that's why
we're looking at identifying sides in
triangles so here's a right angle
triangle we start by calling this angle
over here theta which is a greek letter
and i want to name each of these three
sides in relation to theta okay now
because it's a right angle triangle uh
you've got two shorter signs and then
this longest side which is always
opposite the right angle and as we know
that longer side has this special name
the hypotenuse which we learned in
pythagoras theorem okay so that one's
always the hypotenuse no matter which
angle you're looking at because it's a
unique sign but these other two signs
how shall i name them well i can see
that this side down the bottom
well it's next to the angle theta next
to another word for that is adjacent so
we call this the adjacent side and then
you've got this other one which all the
way on the other side it's opposite it's
facing
theta okay so you can see it's looking
all the way across so you've got the
hypotenuse which is always the longest
side that's always opposite the right
angle you've got the adjacent side down
here and then you've got the opposite
side all the way across the other side
of the triangle from theta okay now the
important thing to get is that even
though the hypotenuse stays the same
whichever angle you're looking at
the opposite and adjacent sides they
will switch around depending on your
point of view so if i draw the same
triangle again
okay
here we go and i've got my right angle
which means that this side over here is
the hypotenuse
so now if i look from up here okay uh if
i this is a different angle so i'm going
to call it alpha
which is another greek letter
uh now the hypotenuse is still the
hypotenuse it's still the longest side
okay but my opposite and my adjacent
sides have switched over you can see
that
this side up here the vertical one
that's the one that's next to or
adjacent to alpha so now it's the
adjacent side and of course if i look
all the way across from the other side
the opposite side is down here now
so
the tricky thing to get is that your
adjacent and your opposite side they
change depending on your point of view
and that happens all the time in real
life okay so we want to think about well
which perspective are we looking from
okay
now
we want to be able to talk about how all
of these sides relate to each other and
that's what the trigonometric ratios are
about
after which trigonometry is net so
the trigonometric ratios
or it's often shortened to
trig ratios
there's three of them
which match up to the relationships
between the sides okay so let's redraw
this guy
so if i got theta down here that means
i've got the opposite which i'm going to
abbreviate to opp the adjacent side
which i'll abbreviate like this and the
hypotenuse okay so i've got my right
angle here
so the three ratios are they're called
sine
cosine
and
tangent and it's a bit long so we
abbreviate them we call this one well
sine is just one syllable but we write
it without the e on the end we call this
one cos and we abbreviate this one to
tan
okay so the way it works is that it's a
ratio each one is a ratio between a pair
of sides so i would write it as sine of
this angle theta
is equal to the opposite side on the
hypotenuse opposite side on
hypotenuse that's sine cos
is the adjacent side on the hypotenuse
and the last one is tan
which is the opposite side this one on
the adjacent side that's the two shorter
sides
okay and you might notice as well that's
actually also equal to sine theta on cos
theta because if i did this divided by
this the hypotenuse these denominators
would cancel you'd just be left left
with these numerators opposite on
adjacent
okay which gives you the same ratio so
um a mnemonic device uh from remembering
uh all of this because it's quite hard
is to notice that you've got uh if you
like that's o over
h a over h and this one is o over a so s
goes with o h so people write s o h sine
is opposite of hypotenuse
cos goes with a and h
cosine equals adjacent on hypotenuse and
t goes with o and a
tan
equals opposite on adjacent so we read
that as sokka toa which is a bit
long and awkward and not a real word but
it does help us to remember what all the
ratios are